this is the same problem that we had in
the last video but instead of trying to
figure out whether the data supply
sufficient evidence to conclude that the
engines meet the actual emission
requirement and all of the hypothesis
testing I thought I would also use the
same data that we had in the last video
to actually come up with a 95 percent
confidence interval so you can ignore
the question right here you can ignore
all of this I'm just using that same
data to come up with a 95 percent
confidence interval for the actual mean
emission for this new engine design so
we want to find a 95 percent 95 percent
confidence confidence interval and as
you could imagine because we only have
10 samples right here we're going to
want to use a t-distribution and right
down here I have a t-table and we want a
95% confidence interval so we want to
think about the the range of T values
that 95 or the range that 95 percent of
T values will fall under so let's think
about it this way so let me draw a T
distribution let me draw a T
distribution right over here so the T
distribution looks very similar to a
normal distribution but it has fatter
tails
it has fatter tails this end and this
end will be fatter than in a normal
distribution and then in it we want to
find an interval so this is if we this
is a normalized t-distribution the mean
is going to be 0 and we want to find an
interval of T values between some
negative value here and some positive
value here that contains 95 that
contains 95 percent of the probability
so this right here has to be 95 percent
and to figure what these critical T
values are at this end and this end we
can just use a T table and we're going
to use the two-sided version of this
because we're symmetric around the
center so you look at the two-sided we
want a 95% confidence interval so we're
going to look right over here 95%
confidence interval we have 10 data
points which means we have 9 degrees of
freedom so 9 degrees of freedom for our
10 data points we just took 10 minus
so if we look over here for that type so
for a t-distribution with 9 degrees of
freedom you're going to have 95% of the
probability is going to be contained
within a t-value of so the T value is
going to be between negative so this
value right here is 2.262 and this value
right here is negative 2.262
that's what this right here tells us
that if you are if you contain all the
values that are less than 2.262 away
from the center of your T distribution
you will contain 95% of the probability
so that is our T distribution right
there let me make it very clear this is
our T distribution T distribution so if
you randomly pick a T value from this T
distribution it has a 95% chance of
being within this far from the mean or
maybe we should write it this way if I
pick a random T value if I take a random
T statistic there's a 94 let me write it
this way there's a 95% chance there is a
95% chance that a random T statistic is
going to be less than 2.262 2.262
and greater than and greater than
negative negative 2.262 95% chance now
when we took this sample we have also we
can also derive a random T statistic
from this we have our sample mean and
our sample standard deviation our sample
mean here our sample mean here is 17
point one seven figured that out on the
last video just add these up divided by
10 and our sample standard deviation
here is two point nine eight so the T
statistic that we can derive from this
information right over here so let me
write it over here the T statistic that
we can derive from this and you can view
this T statistic as being a random
sample from a T distribution a T
distribution with 9 degrees of freedom
so the T the T statistic that we can
derive from that is
going to be our mean seventeen point one
seven minus the true the true mean of
our population or actually we say the
true mean of our sampling distribution
which is also going to be the same as
the true mean of our population that's
our population mean over there / / S
which is two point nine eight over the
square root the square root of our
number of samples we've seen this
multiple times this right here is the T
statistic so by taking this sample you
can say that we've randomly sampled at
ISTA tist ik for this nine degree of
freedom T distribution so there's a 95%
chance that this thing right over here
this thing right over here is going to
be between is going to be less than two
point two six two and greater than
negative two point two six two so the
95% 95% probability 95% probability
still is still applies to this right
here now we just have to do some math
calculate these things let me get my
calculator out and get the calculator
out and so let me just calculate this
denominator right over here so we have
two point nine eight divided by the
square root the square root of ten so
that's point nine four two three Oh
point nine four two three so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to multiply
both sides of this equation by this
expression right over here so if I do
that so let me just do that right over
so if I multiply this entire this is
really two equations one or two
inequalities I should say that this
quantity is greater than this quantity
and that this quantity is greater than
that quantity but we can operate on all
of them at the same time this entire
inequality so what we want to do is
multiply this entire inequality by this
value right over here and we just
calculated that that value let me write
it over here the two point nine eight
I'll write it all right over here two
point nine eight over the square root of
10 is equal to 0.9 point nine four two
so if I multiply
if I multiply this entire inequality by
0.9 for two I get on this left hand side
over here I have negative two point two
six two times times point nine four two
and it's a positive number that we're
multiplying the whole inequality by so
the inequality signs are still going to
be in the same direction is less than
well we're multiplying this we're
multiplying this whole expression by the
same expression in the denominator so
it'll cancel out so we're just going to
be less than seventeen point one seven
minus our population mean which is going
to be less than two point two six two
times once again once again 0.94 to let
me scroll over to to the right a little
bit nine four to just be clear I just
I'm just multiplying both all three
sides of this inequality by this number
right over here in the middle this
cancels out so if I multiply I'll just
write out here point nine four two point
nine four two point nine four to this
and this is the same number so that's
why those cancel out and now let's hit
the calculator to figure out what these
numbers are so point if we have the
point nine four two times two point two
six two so we're going to say times two
point two six two is two point one three
so this is going to be so this number
right over here on the right hand side
this number on the right hand side is
two point one three two point one three
this number on the left is just the
negative of that so it's negative two
point one three negative two point one
three and then we still have our
inequalities is going to be less than
seventeen point one seven minus the mean
which is less than two point one three
now what I want to do is I actually want
to solve for this mean and I don't like
that negative sign of the mean I'd
rather have the swapped around I'd
rather have the mean minus seventeen
point one seven so what I'm going to do
is multiply this entire inequality by
negative one if you do that
if you multiply the entire thing times
negative 1 this quantity right here this
negative 2 point 1 3 will become a
positive 2 point 1 3 but since we are
multiplying an inequality by a negative
number you have to swap the inequality
sign so this less than will become a
greater than this negative this negative
mu will become a positive mu this
positive 17.1 7 will become a negative
17 point 1 7 where we have to swap this
inequality sign as well and this
positive 2 point 1 3 will become a
negative two point one three and we're
almost like we just want to solve for M
you have this inequality expressed in
terms of MU so what we can do is now
just add 17 point one seven to all three
sides of this inequality and we are left
with two point 1 3 plus 17 point 1 7 is
greater than mu minus 17 point 1 7 plus
17 point 1 7 is just going to be mu
which is greater than so this is greater
than mu which is greater than negative
two point one 3 plus 17 point one seven
or a more natural way to write it since
we actually have a bunch of greater than
signs that this is actually the largest
number and that and this are sorry this
is actually the smallest number and this
over here is actually the largest number
is doctory flip you can just rewrite
this inequality the other way so now we
can write we can write actually let's
just figure out what these values are so
we have two point 1 3 plus so we have
two point 1 3 plus 17 point 1 7 so that
is that is the high end of our range so
that is 19 point three so this value
right over here so this is 19 let me do
it in that same color this value right
here is 19 point three is going to be
greater than mu which is going to be
greater than and this is negative two
point one three plus 17 point one seven
or we could have 17 point one seven
minus two point one three which gives us
fifteen point zero 4 15 point oh four 15
0.04
and remember the whole thing all of this
we started with there was a 95% chance
that a random t-statistic will fall in
this interval will fall in this interval
we had a random T statistic and all we
did is a bunch of math so the 90 there's
a 95% chance that any of these steps are
true and so there's a 95% chance that
this is true there's a 95% chance that
the true population mean which is the
same thing as the mean of the sampling
distribution of the sample mean there's
a 95% chance or we're confident that
there's a 95% chance that it will fall
in this interval and we're done